strongholds themselves is a brand new
feature within Diablo 4. yeah yeah
absolutely so conceptually strongholds
There Are Places of importance to the
world and the people of sanctuary that
have been overrun by evil pretty simple
right
um so uh this way this ends up working
in practice is as you're exploring and
navigating the huge world of Diablo 4 in
sanctuary there will be multiple
strongholds in every uh in each of our
five zones for you to discover and these
are completely unique so each stronghold
is a unique location they have different
stories they have different uh gameplay
objectives bosses even some of the uh
rewards are unique to each specific
stronghold
um and uh much like our campaign these
are private experiences they're they're
just for you uh or you and your party uh
if you choose to bring some friends
um so once you've completed uh the
stronghold uh then uh the space becomes
to uh becomes uh something that we refer
to as a public space where you then
might encounter and interact with other
players if you want that's cool so like
what type of spaces can strongholds
themselves end up uh kind of like
changing to after after you end up uh
encountering them and then maybe like
conquering them or going through them
yourself yeah so um that's like actually
one of the things that I'm most excited
uh to talk about the system is that when
you conquer a stronghold there's a
there's a lasting impact on the world
and um we actually unlock a bunch of
additional content for you to explore uh
and engage with after the fact but I
think I want to talk about that a little
bit later all right uh yeah we I think
we have footage as well for the the
strongholds that we can actually like
kind of throw up here and maybe we can
explain like what what players are uh
kind of experiencing or like what they
would experience when they're going
through you brought a clip yeah I did I
found out
the stronghold you're looking at here uh
this is called hopes light
um uh kind of uh in the in the jagged uh
shores of Northern scosglenn uh there's
this great Lighthouse called hopes light
and its flame has been extinguished
um
so uh you know uh the particular the
port town of Maryland uh nearby is
particularly affected it's the only Port
Town in all of Scotland they consider
this uh sacred place and obviously the
the sailors of these perilous Waters
they kind of rely on the lighthouse to
navigate uh so you're kind of high level
objective is just find a path through uh
to the lighthouse and figure out what
happened
um and you know as the player when you
arrive there you notice the drown have
risen
um the drown or this brand new monster
family in Diablo 4 they're the super
mysterious creatures that kind of
shamble up on the Shores from the depths
of the sea and they drag these like
bells and mysterious Idols with them
nobody really knows like who they are or
what they want but one of the other
things that we're super excited to kind
of do with strongholds is to try and
showcase these monster families kind of
give you a glimpse into uh into what
they're about yeah because I know like
um back during BlizzCon we we actually
uh Bliss on 2019 when we revealed Diablo
4 we actually did showcase the drown for
the first time and then since then we
actually I know we had a quarterly
update blog that talked a little bit
about monster families uh where we even
talked about like familiars for instance
and so forth that that were up there but
like yeah this is
um kind of like the the first like
updated look I think people are seeing
of the drowned here in the NAA
stronghold uh which is really cool to
see oh legendary
I never knew what it was because I was
playing with the UI off
um but uh actually that might be a you
know going back to kind of strongholds
at the at the system level
um and you know kind of like why uh you
the player might care uh so strongholds
they provide you with a lot of really
awesome rewards uh obviously you know
you slay a bunch of monsters you kill a
boss you're going to get a bunch of uh
XP and loot uh beyond that uh
strongholds also reward you with a high
amount of renown uh Renown is another
new system uh in Diablo 4 uh and just to
quickly summarize that Renown uh it
rewards you with engaging with multiple
various open world activities you gain
noun in each of the five regions of the
game and when you hit certain Milestones
of renown you'll get rewards you'll get
really cool stuff like additional potion
charges skill points even Paragon points
at the later Milestones so yeah but uh
beyond all this like strictly you know
gold XP lude we're now beyond all this
strictly character progression stuff
I mentioned for uh conquering a
stronghold has a lasting impact on the
world and unlocks a bunch of additional
content so when you've completed a
stronghold uh and you know in some cases
you've kind of uh you know cleansed the
evil as much as it can be uh in in a
world like Sanctuary uh people feel safe
enough to come back and so
um you know some some strongholds will
actually become towns after you know
they'll have vendors uh I guess
waypoints other strongholds might unlock
a short a shortcut path to a different
area a waypoint uh side quests many
strongholds actually unlock dungeons so
you know if you are hunting for aspects
in the Codex of power or you're engaging
with The Whispers of the dead or
nightmare Dungeons and game systems
you're probably really going to want to
discover
that's awesome so yeah like just like
the the last ring we had we talked a
little bit about codex and power so
um and you know obviously going through
dungeons ends up unlocking or finding
new codexes
um so yeah to actually compete are
completing strongholds I will unlock new
dungeons that will let you get more
codecs uh or more Powers within your
codex itself so it kind of like opens up
more and more as especially with with
strongholds itself that's that's awesome
and and the the fact that it's a lasting
impact on the world is is pretty pretty
crazy can you see strongholds like on
the map like as you're kind of like
traversing through Sanctuary yeah yeah
absolutely just so like like any other
uh area of the game you know it stores
this kind of undiscovered space and then
once you've discovered it they show up
on the map they have some iconography to
let you know that hey there's a cool
piece of content for you to go do here
nice and then and players themselves
will see tons of these all throughout uh
all like as sanctuary that they can
actually uh either maybe like do a
little bit later or come back to and so
forth from that side yeah yeah
absolutely they're like I said there's
there's multiple strongholds in every
region and uh one of the so strong
strongholds actually have a like a
minimum level so you might actually uh
you know discover one that you're just
under leveled for there's nothing
stopping you from trying to take it off
but you're probably gonna die unless
you're playing hardcore
maybe you make a new character because
he died yeah exactly that that's when
you question it a little bit Yeah so and
that's another question we get a lot is
like is Hardcore gonna be in Diablo 4
and yes it will be um so that's when you
would watch the idea of wanting to try
to conquer a strong hold at a lower
level so yeah
um but yeah with the and and a lot again
this is just a a brand new feature for
for Diablo 4 in itself so it actually
allows you to essentially just uh
continue to add additional content to
the game and change the world completely
because the fact that you can actually
get new waypoints or uh you know a whole
new town that you can actually interact
with with new you know vendors and so
forth from that side is also just uh
completely
yeah absolutely and a lot of the new
content that you unlock uh it was also
kind of like part of the renowned system
so you complete a stronghold then you
get you know side quests and Dungeons
and all these things also feed into the
renowned system uh so yeah there's a lot
of cool stuff uh kind of completing a
stronghold is kind of like only half of
half of the future right and the other
half is all the additional stuff that
gets unlocked afterwards that's very
cool yeah strongholds is uh uh sounding
awesome I I know like myself I've I mean
I've played the game people yelling here
really soon but the perks are working
out you heard it here first we play the
game we play the game that person
working at blizzard uh but yeah it's uh
it most definitely is a cool feature and
I I you know had strongholds completely
changed like the whole term map and just
having like even a waypoint closer to
wherever you need to go for a dungeon is
also really great to have so
um of course uh an art provided here
this footage here a barbarian kind of
going through and I know this Barbarian
has got like some some legendary type of
gear and like some unique skills and so
forth that are like kind of modified
based off the gear so show off a little
bit of a higher level Barbarian for
people
um uh because the parts just a ton of
fun to play yeah super fun cool well I
know that
um we kind of went over a little bit
about armor systems and uh the the
strongholds themselves we do uh a lot of
the feedback from the last stream that's
like you know they've people were hoping
that we spend a little bit more time on
Q a